so now you've learned the layout of
simple app engine app that uses
endpoints you started out by getting the
project Udacity github repository
however there are various other
templates for you to use when you create
a maven project and these are called
archetypes to create a new maven project
using an archetype open a console
terminal window and change to a
directory where you want to build your
project from the command line invoke
maven by typing mvn archetype colon
generate hit return this is the first
time you're doing this maven needs to
actually download some things to show
you the available archetypes but now we
see all the different archetypes that
you could use it's kind of an
overwhelming list you can filter it so
let's see what archetypes we've got for
App Engine so i'll enter App Engine here
and we've got 3 here 3 App Engine
archetypes let's see what we've got for
endpoints okay we've got to you can do
other filtering if you want and the
archetypes can change over time but now
I'm going to go ahead and create an
archetype using the hello endpoints
archetype so this is similar to the
hello world endpoints project that you
got from Udacity but it has a little
more functionality and a little more
pizzazz to it so here we want to so i'm
going to enter to take the default
number 3 and then the group ID is really
the package name so I'm going to call
mine com google training at a loop and
then i'm going to call mine the artifact
can be training take the default
snapshot the packages com google
training then it's a quick summary of
what we're going to do just press yes
NTS okay build success so now if I
explore my directory I have all the
files for my project so now I can go
into Eclipse and import this project
that i just created from the archetype
existing project and there it is that's
my project training's of it generics i'm
going to change the name new hello world
worried about the arrows resolve those
later finish tin you when you see over
here I have my new hello world project
and I could just go ahead and deploy
that right away to localhost let's do it
oh no launching dev server has
encountered a problem can't find maven
installation embedded all right i forgot
about that you always have to remember
this when you get a new project say ok
then you go to run as run configurations
then we need to find the one that we
just used and we need to make sure that
the maven runtime is external not
embedded dev app server is now running
let's go to localhost ok I needed to
refresh the browser and you see I've got
the new the UI for the new project could
also go look at the endpoint API through
available here in the API Explorer this
is also called the hello world API was
slightly different greeting so we'll
call it school get greeting oops don't
know what the idea is list greetings and
here are the greetings so it's up to you
if you'd like to go ahead and create
that archetype and explore the project I
leave that to you but I do want you to
know that there's lots of different
templates available for creating maven
projects